في هذه الأيام ، تعيش Samsung في حالة أزمة مستمرة ،
على الأقل هكذا
ستصفها الشركة ، نعتقد
أن الأزمة هي فرصتنا لمستقبلنا ،
ويبدو أن ابتكار أزمة Samsung يساوي الابتكار ،
الشيء الوحيد الذي تجيده Samsung هو
أنهم  عدوانية للغاية في الطريقة
التي يتعاملون بها مع مجال التكنولوجيا في
بعض الأحيان بشكل مفرط في العدوانية ولكن في
المخطط الكبير للأشياء ، يكون الأمر جيدًا
لأنه يبقيهم على
حافة التكنولوجيا الرائدة هنا في
المختبرات السرية لهذه الشركات الكورية الجنوبية
التي يبحث المهندسون عنها
الشيء الكبير التالي لشركة Samsung
هو السجادة الرقمية التي ترغب في
إحضار التجربة ، تحويل السيارة إلى هاتف محمول
وهذا هو السبب في أن هذا هو
الشيء الذي
تراه Samsung في المستقبل القريب حيث
تقود السيارات بأنفسهم والسائقين
الذين سيحتاجون إلى الترفيه قبل خمس سنوات.
لاعب ونظام
معلومات وترفيه خاص بالسيارات ، ولكن بحلول عام 2016 ، أنفق ثمانية
مليارات دولار لشراء شركة
Harmon في الولايات المتحدة في غضون عامين فقط  آذان لاحقًا أصبحت Samsung
الموزع الأول في العالم في الصناعة
بإيرادات تبلغ حوالي خمسة مليارات دولار
وفقًا للمحللين وكنت أنت
الرجل الآلي في
مكان آخر في الحرم الجامعي تعمل فرق العمل على
تكنولوجيا الرعاية الصحية وهو مجال جديد نسبيًا
لشركة Samsung في عام 2010 أصدرت الشركة
أول جهاز طبي في
سرير محسوب لتحويل الرعاية الصحية إلى
محرك نمو جديد مؤخرًا ،
ركزت سامسونج على أجهزة الاستشعار والأجهزة القابلة للارتداء ،
طور هؤلاء الرجال الآليون منتجًا يسمونه
نظام التحفيز المعزز للمشي.
الإحساس بالوخز ، تلك هي المستشعرات الموجودة
على الوركين وقياس الزوايا التي تم إنشاؤها
بواسطة المسافة التي يتحرك بها كل ساقي
واستغرق الأمر المشي ثم
ترفع المحركات ساقي بناءً على تلك المشية الشخصية التي
تمنح عضلاتي دفعة كبيرة من
الخير ،
يعتقد الفريق أن هذا يمكن أن يساعد يومًا ما
المستخدمين المسنين والمعاقين من خلال
العلاج الطبيعي وممارسة Samsung
تركز أعينها على صناعة الهياكل الخارجية
وتقول إنها قد تصل قيمتها إلى ما يقرب من ستة مليارات
دولار في غضون العقد المقبل بالقرب من السندات التي
يطورها مهندسون آخرون لتكنولوجيا
لمساعدة المكفوفين على رؤية
كيفية عملها ، فأنا
أعمى إلى حد ما مع هذه الزجاجات نصف غير الشفافة
إنه ضبابي للغاية ولا يمكنني رؤية أي شيء
بعد ذلك نظرًا لمجموعة أدوات الواقع الافتراضي المقترنة
بهاتف Samson والتطبيق. كيف أرى أن
خوارزميات البرنامج تساعد في اكتشاف
حتى أضعف الخطوط العريضة وأيضًا عكس
الألوان وتحسين التباين حتى تتمكن من
رؤية هذا أمر لا يصدق للمديرين التنفيذيين
مثل Kim the lab نفسه هو ابتكار حقيقي من Samsung ،
فإن ثقافة بدء التشغيل الإبداعي الخاصة بهم
هي أنني أشعر باختلاف شديد مع
انخفاض مبيعات الهواتف
الذكية العالمية ، حيث يحتاج صانع الهواتف الذكية الأول في العالم إلى
منتج جديد رائج
يتسابق للابتكار ولكن ليس للتسويق
في أعقاب العديد من
عمليات إطلاق المنتجات الفاشلة  بما في ذلك الإصدار
الأول لأحدث إصدار من galaxy fold ، قد تدرك سامسونج الآن
الحاجة إلى موازنة السرعة مع
التنفيذ